foreign
cancellation today begins with a report
in the New York Post about a major and
important controversy quote an angry
traveler has shared their frustrations
over a woman who had the audacity quote
unquote to request a seat swap so she
could sit next to her kid in a resurface
Reddit post now going viral the
flummoxed flyer said that it was quote
not my problem they didn't book together
when asked to switch seats the
unidentified traveler was on a
trans-pacific flight from Japan sitting
in a window seat while the toddler was
in the middle seat the tot's mom was in
the road directly behind them also
seated in the middle she asked me
quoting now and just made a switch with
her so she could have my window seat
next to her daughter and I'd have to
take her middle seat a row back
the user wrote hell to the F no the
peeve pasture continued to the post
worse as we were surrounded by others
from her tour group that she could have
asked for three-way trade instead or the
tour operator the audacity to just ask
me and expect an inferior trade on my
side
now many of the comments on Reddit and
on social media as this critically
important story has been shared far and
wide have come down against the man in
the window seat or the I don't know if
it's man the person in the window seat
claiming that it was his responsibility
to Forfeit the seat that he likely paid
extra money for and accept a much less
comfortable arrangement for a flight
across the Pacific Ocean all because
some stranger he doesn't know failed to
plan ahead
so as always
the internet Jury has ruled incorrectly
on this case
There are rules for seat trading on
airlines rules that this woman defied in
fact there are many rules governing
airline travel rules that uh that many
people constantly flout
these are not rules made or enforced by
the airlines themselves they have their
own rules but these are rules that exist
at a deeper level rules that that are
written on the human heart I'm not
speaking about the laws of man but
rather natural laws laws that we should
all understand innately as human beings
with rational Souls
and if you don't understand these laws
then I will explain them to you right
now okay we have in the past touched on
many different aspects of air travel but
it's become apparent to me that that I
need to provide one resource with all of
the rules laid out in a clear and
accessible format and that's what we're
going to do today so this is the
definitive list of of rules of laws for
air travel we'll deal with the question
of uh seat swapping when we get there
but the rules begin well before you step
foot on the plane now in the interest of
time I'll only be able to cover the
rules that govern the time when you wake
up in the morning on the day of your
flight to the moment when you sit in
your seat on the plane
so this is this is the beginning of the
definitive list but it will not be the
entire list okay so let's proceed rule
number one
you dress like a civilized well-groomed
adult
if you're not that kind of adult then
you need to pretend that you are nobody
stumbles accidentally onto a plane you
have to book tickets you have to pack
you have to engage in some kind of
planning ahead of time so there's no
excuse to not to be completely dressed
and showered and presentable when you
get on the plane now
if I knocked on your door in the middle
of the night well you probably call the
cops but let's say that you answer the
door you you'd be in your pajamas maybe
wearing slippers hair messy matted teeth
not brushed blurry eyed you know
unshowered confused and I could not
complain about having to look at you in
that disheveled and disgusting State
because I knocked on your door in the
middle of the night but when I see you
at the airport or on a plane I did not
knock on your door in the middle of the
night we are meeting out in public in a
place we've both paid money to be and
planned ahead of time to be so I should
not have to be exposed to your middle of
the night look I should not have to see
you in your pajamas wearing slippers and
a bathrobe this this is this is an
airport it's not your bedroom
so put on some clothes you sloppy freak
that's rule number one rule number two
on that note there will be no sleeping
in the terminal okay I was at the
airport a couple of weeks ago sitting at
the gate and by far not the first time
this has happened there's a man five
feet from me laid out on the ground
curled up in the fetal position this has
grown man jacket pulled over him like a
blanket fast asleep now once again this
is an airport it's not your bedroom it's
also not a refugee camp so forget about
the fact that by sleeping on the ground
at the airport you are displaying an
extremely unreasonable amount of faith
in the airport's janitorial staff
the truth is that that patch of floor
you're lying on was probably last clean
during like the first Bush
Administration not to mention you're
displaying an even more unreasonable
amount of faith in other people
do you actually trust other humans
enough to become voluntarily unconscious
amid a huge crowd of them
well you shouldn't but that's not even
the point the point is that I don't want
to have to look at you like that it's
undignified it's embarrassing okay you
can take a nap when you get to the hotel
the airport is a place for being awake
and tired and miserable like the rest of
us
rule number three
so you got into the airport you're awake
like everybody else like a like a
civilized adult now we're boarding the
plane when boarding the plane remember
that you're on you are on stoplight time
okay what do I mean by that well when
you're sitting at a stop light and the
light turns green and then a second
passes and you still haven't moved the
cars behind you will start blaring their
horns and screaming curses at you and
throwing eggs and tomatoes at your
windshield and they will be morally
justified in doing so that's because at
a stop light each second counts as 10
minutes if you wait two seconds to move
that you've actually been sitting there
for 20 minutes three seconds been a half
hour and now it's both morally and from
what I understand legally acceptable for
the cars behind you to Ram into you and
force you through the intersection
now when boarding a plane time works
exactly the same way it's not normal
time you have to understand that you
have less than one second therefore to
Stow your bags and get in your seat okay
you're getting on the plane keep it
moving Stow the baggage so you have less
than a second to do it if you bring a
bag on board that doesn't fit in the
overhead storage and now we have to wait
not only seconds but even minutes
minutes while the situation is resolved
you have in effect delayed us by years
we are years behind schedule because of
you and we hate you for it
one of the note about boarding a plane
if you're running late for your flight
and and will now be boarding after
everybody else has already taken their
seats
you're not going to like this but this
is the rule the rule dictates that you
don't board at all your trip is canceled
you're not flying
because first of all you've held us all
up and now you have to pay the price for
it but also second the other people in
your row now assume that you aren't
coming and they have experienced the
joyful Elation at the thought that
they'll have extra space on their flight
it is deeply painful to believe that the
person next to you isn't showing up only
to see them appear out of nowhere five
seconds before the doors shut sweaty
exhausted like out of breath happy that
they made the flight
totally unconcerned by by the trauma
that's been being inflicted on you now
that you realize that this sweaty person
is me sitting next to you
so if you're running that late you don't
get to board Rule Number Four
to deal with the issue we would began
with if you have a problem with your
seat you need to trade trade with
somebody else on the flight you may only
propose a lateral trade window seat for
Window Seat aisle for now because I'm
generous I'll even allow you to propose
a window for Aisle or aisle for window
trade but what you cannot ever do under
any circumstance is try to trade your
middle seat for someone else's end seat
too big a favor to ask if someone you
don't know it's like going up to some
stranger in a parking garage and asking
them to take your 2011 Toyota Corolla
with a broken air conditioning and 150
000 miles on it in exchange for their
luxury sedan
well I guess no seat on a modern Airline
is tantamount to a luxury sedan so it's
more like asking to exchange your beat
up disgusting Toyota Corolla for a
slightly less beat up and disgusting
Toyota Corolla either way it's it's a
laughable proposition and it's
inappropriate to even request
rule number five finally for now
once you're sitting in your seat here
are all the things you may not do you
may not lean back your chair seats are
equipped with this function but not
because you're supposed to actually use
it the recline option on the seat is
just there as a test to see who is a
sociopath if you hit the button you fail
the test
you may not eat any food that gives off
a strong smell or makes any kind of
sound so this rule basically rules out
all food except for white plain white
bread is all you're allowed to eat on
the plane if you're sitting next to me
anyway
you may not speak to the person next to
you unless you're spoken to but they
also are following the same rule which
means that nobody's speaking at all if
you're in the middle seat as I've
explained in the past
you have no Privileges and no human
rights you are worse than a second class
citizen you don't exist
this means that you don't have
permission to use either of your
armrests your superiors on the end get
both of their armrests you get nothing
you're also not allowed to inconvenience
the aisle seat by getting up to use the
bathroom you must sit there legs
together arms folded head bound bound
down in silence for the duration of the
flight
now if you're sitting in the window seat
you need to use the bathroom you may
impose this inconvenience on the aisle
seat but only once per six hours of the
flight so if your flight is less than
six hours you're not permitted access to
the bathroom at all
now this as I said only a partial list
of rules enough to get you on the plane
and seated as for how to conduct
yourself during the flight and get off
the flight uh well we'll have to cover
those rules at a different time what I
would recommend is that nobody take any
flights at all until I've had a chance
to cover the entire list of rules for
now though anyone who has ever violated
rules one through five
is of course banned from flying from
here on out and also obviously today
canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to members block become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
oopsy over the members block if not
we'll talk to you tomorrow God
[Music]
[Applause]